finalmente El Banco Central europeo
sigue la ruta esperada y aumenta 50
puntos básicos los tipos de interés la
decisión del Banco Central europeo era
sin duda una decisión de riesgo todo el
mundo estaba pendiente de lo que pudiera
decidir especialmente debido a las
últimas turbulencias que ha habido en
los últimos días principalmente con la
caída del banco de silicon Valley en
Estados Unidos pero también los
problemas y la crisis que ha tenido el
banco Credit swiss y que sumió en una
fuerte caída a las bolsas europeas ayer
la entrada la entidad ha decidido
mantener así los tipos de interés de
interés aumentar los 50 puntos sobre
todo porque apenas tenía margen hay que
tener en cuenta que la inflación en la
eurozona está disparada con más de un
ocho por ciento a pesar de que los
precios de la energía han descendido los
de los alimentos ahora mismo están
aumentando sin parar el Banco Central
europeo tiene como objetivo mantener al
ciento la inflación y creía que con esta
medida es la única solución para poder
intentar reducir esta inflación en las
últimas horas algunos analistas
apuntaban que quizás El Banco Central
europeo finalmente aumentaría 0,25
puntos pero es una era un mensaje que no
todo el mundo estaba de acuerdos había
temores de que quizás esto enviaría un
mensaje contrario y no tranquiría no
tranquilizaría los mercados financieros
Así que el Banco Central europeo
finalmente ha dicho que estará pendiente
de las últimas noticias de lo que pueda
ocurrir en las últimas horas pero que
tomará todas las decisiones necesarias
un mensaje muy claro para tranquilizar
ahora mismo los mercados financieros que
estaban pendientes de cualquier decisión
y especialmente de esta decisión que se
considera que es una de las más
importantes del año